at what point did you think that this is
something that could be a movie in your
life I mean you can't really make this
up that's part of it I think it was
probably about five years after the
events that we first started talking we
started talking and then when we started
working with Judd Apatow he was like he
really encouraged us to kind of make
this a story that was for everyone in
the story that even though it had a lot
of sad parts to it a lot of intense
parts that could be really funny and so
it's really with his kind of guidance
that we started the process what was the
hardest thing to be found to share with
an audience in writing this film I would
say for me personally all the stuff I
have with my parents was the toughest
stuff for me to write and and I resisted
it for a long time and then Judd kind of
very correctly pushed me to explore some
of that some more that was probably the
stuff from me that felt the most
personal especially since it's in
process don't take anything that out but
I've always been pretty stoic about my
help and so I think for me writing it
was kind of introducing this part of my
life that had been pretty private before
to people that we collaborated with and
then now to audiences who asked me how
my blood oxygen level is now and it's
good it's very good these days it's in
range guys and in casting the film and
working with everybody what was the
start of the possibly did you always
know that that one of you would be in it
or just Kamal would be in it or what was
that like in terms of making it a real
film
emilie audition didn't get it the only
was better what can I I [ __ ] learn my
line it's not easy you gotta be off-book
yet not an actress and so it was always
the idea was always that Camille would
play himself and that we would find an
actress to play the version of myself in
the movie which we did we I think we did
a bang-up job with was doing we're
taking all of the credit for Zoe
you can take all the credit I like that
how do you approach the film in terms of
with MLA and the story was it something
that you're trying to achieve that I'm
going to be like this real person or is
it just a character in a movie I think
for actors like the prospect of playing
a real person is always very delicious
and and I was like oh well like study
her and learn how Emily conducts herself
and then I met Emily I was like oh she's
just like me oh okay I guess I'll just
be myself oh um you know it sounds like
a really weird situation
um and I guess in us with other people
it might have been but it felt really
natural and really easy and um I think
it helped it there were some
fictionalized aspects of this story and
that allowed me to feel like I didn't
have to be mimetic in some way and also
Emily was like incredibly gracious and I
loved spending time with her so it was
it was like a lot of learning by osmosis
what in the story really made you want
to be part of the film Holly were you
excited about doing it well you know
there was there was something about the
movie this felt you know the deal is
that it felt other there was something
other about it and it is because it's
real you know it had that thing of like
wow this is too weird for life but so
it's life you know it had that that
aspect to it that was arresting you know
on first read it was like wow that you
know maybe I should do this this is not
a political film and it's and I'm
curious but now in the process of making
the film that the world we live in it
coming out like what do you have any
thoughts for all of you about a film
like this and the story and where it
falls in this country in the world right
now okay I will well I always say thank
I like to quote Bono if I may
now that is a bet there's a back story
here Bono saw the movie and was blown
away by this is a true story
because his song is in the trailer and
you don't need to know why but he saw
the movie Bono is a rock star he's got
that gear - yeah not Sonny Bono
that's bono right yeah okay but he
described it as a serious film disguised
as a rom-com
and i think it is that but it's not
purposely that that's the I think that's
the beauty of the film is it's about
something else and yet that's there
underneath it's there which is good
because it also shows you how love and
relationships transcends all that
[ __ ] sorry really
all right whatever we're here right yeah
we're all right don't you know you're
going to say the last line right of your
play but yeah so that's what I love
about it is that there is there is if
you want to say there's a message there
I think there is but I think it's done
in the most unique way that even even
kind of accentuates the message even
more it I think this movie takes the
radical makes the radical political
stance that Muslims are normal people
you know I saw you have dinner yeah they
have dinner actually this was very very
exciting the cholita today the
english-language newspaper in Pakistan
just like the it's called dawn it's the
biggest english-language newspaper they
like reviewed the movie today and it got
me like really emotion they loved it by
the way they love ya
they give it the two and a half stars
well no they really really loved it and
they talked a lot about how it sort of
normalizes Muslims and it's crazy that
that's something that needs to be done
but as Ray was saying it's sort of a
happy side-effect we didn't we weren't
trying to make a statement we're just
trying to tell our story with all these
wonderful people